[Music]
thank you
the top stories live from the Sky News
City Studio
defense giant BAE Systems and Microsoft
team up to equip defense programs with
Cloud technology
there's a super dry Plum just the
fashion retailer contemplates a sale of
new shares
is the UK's Credit Card Market broken
are here from the fintech that claims it
is
and as company insolvency's rise we'll
be hearing how struggling smes can Stave
off the worst
[Music]
good morning this is Ian King live an
hour of business and economic news from
the Heart of the City well we begin
today with the UK's biggest defense
contract of ba systems it's today signed
a strategic agreement with Microsoft
with the aim of supporting its work on
the digital defense capabilities with
Cloud technology under the agreement Bae
expects to develop deploy and manage
such capabilities more rapidly than in
the past enabling data to be more
efficiently used during military
operations would you want me to talk
about this is the Chief Information and
Technology officer at ba systems Julian
crackle Julian welcome to you um what
was the thinking here
I think if you look at the the pace of
advanced technology in the commercial
sector over the last few years it's been
truly astonishing and Microsoft and
others have been absolutely the
Forefront of of that the use of cloud to
create uh development environments where
people we can share information we can
test uh systems we can rapidly update
them you know all of that has moved on
so quickly in the commercial environment
but it hasn't moved as quickly in the
military environment and there are some
good reasons for that uh you know things
like security classification things like
safety qualification uh indeed you know
International regulatory environments a
whole series of reasons why it's just
been a bit more complex but our sense is
working together with Microsoft that we
can really start to break through that
and that now is a great opportunity to
try and take advantage of some of those
commercial Technologies uh combining
that with our understanding of uh the
context in which those technologies will
be applied all those things that I
talked about but also the complexities
of military platforms the environments
that they're going to be used in and so
that combination of of our deep
understanding of the environment our
deep understanding of military
technology and Microsoft's fantastic
understanding of cloud technology I
think is you know it's a really
compelling and exciting
agreement and what was the impetus who
approached who first uh
it's something that you know both of us
I think we're interested in talking to
each other we we on the Bae side have an
enormous amount of technology technology
uh research and we're always interested
to look at and work with Partners uh to
try and move that uh agenda forward so
we're certainly happy to have the
conversation uh and and you know
Microsoft I think are Keen to understand
and work with Partners to understand the
nuances of markets like defense which
are you know which have some
characteristics that are not quite the
same as the commercial sector I mean
Ba's had its own digital design and
Manufacturing capabilities for for
decades why do you need to team up with
Microsoft well let me give you an
example of one of the pilots that we've
been running we over the course of the
last year we run three Pilots through
this program one of them is around
developing the next version of the
combat management system uh uh for a
ship now we've developed many combat
Management Systems over the years and
indeed support most of the current UK
Fleet but those platforms tend to become
over time quite large monolithic bodies
of code they're quite difficult to keep
updated and they're particularly
difficult to bring new capabilities into
quickly
what we've been doing through this
partnership over the last year is
developing the next generation of combat
management system and essentially the
combat management system is bringing
together all of the sensor data around
the ship and presenting that to the
commanders in a clear and understandable
way allowing them to make decisions
about what to do next
through working with Microsoft we've
developed that in a cloud-based way an
agile way it's allowed us to develop in
multiple different sites securely allows
us to test it much more rapidly but
crucially has allowed us to work with
small and medium Enterprises and bring
them in to develop specific capabilities
that we can layer over the top of that
now we've always done that sort of thing
but it's tended historically to be quite
slow laborious requires lots of manual
effort to make sure that we're
segregating the data in the right way
that people can only see the bits they
they should be able to see whereas we've
been able to do that much more quickly
and that's I think fantastic from the
perspective of the smes and fantastic in
terms of the capability that we can
deliver to our customers I mean that is
very interesting because you are going
to be using open architecture for this
so that third parties can get involved
as well does that come with security
risks I mean you've got to really know
who you're working with I mean clearly
one has to think those those things uh
through very carefully I think the
general move towards open architectures
uh Clarity around a standard of
communication is is only a good thing
um it means that uh lots of different
organizations can get involved and can
develop capabilities but you're
absolutely right clearly within that one
has to be very thoughtful about security
classification and who you're working
with but you know in unlocking the power
of technology to deliver capability that
must be the right way forward
particularly in terms of pace I mean you
mentioned there that a maritime
application presumably this will be
deployed over Lancy and air one of the
other Pilots that we ran uh was a drone
program an uncrewed vehicle and what we
were looking at there was the ability to
update the capabilities of that drone
while it was in flight so we had a
distributed team again using the the
Microsoft cloud stack working in
different locations but we were able to
modify the sensor capabilities on this
drone while it was in Flight over the
air and give it new capabilities and you
can you can immediately see the sort of
military utility of that as new threats
or as new adversaries uh become known
that one could uh you know modify
platforms to to deal with that now this
was just a pilot and we've got to be you
know clearly there are significant
constraints on updating in-service
platforms while they're uh while they're
operating but I think as a proof of
concept as an idea to start pushing at
the bounds of how can we adapt
technology more quickly bring more
capability to users and ensure that they
have the best capability to defend the
UK and our allies I think can only be a
good thing obviously uh military
personnel and and the services have a
multitude of different sources from
which they obtain data these days have
there been any takeaways from what's
going on in Ukraine for you in terms of
how data can be deployed in in in in
military situations
um I mean there are lots of lessons that
are have been learned and are being
learned from what's going on in Ukraine
at the moment
I think you're absolutely right the
importance of uh data understanding the
provenance of the data the quality of it
its timeliness and how you can provide
that to commanders to make decisions is
absolutely critical that is only going
to increase in the future and again I
think this agreement uh with uh with
Microsoft combined with our
understanding of of that military
context I think you know absolutely is
the right or you know it comes at an
opportune time to to build on that
future required and does the type with
Microsoft preclude you from working with
any of their competitors uh no it's not
it's not an exclusive deal but what it
does mean is that as well as their
technology uh we're working with their
teams and their people together to to to
bring together agile teams to work
quickly but it it it you know clearly we
work with a whole variety of uh
technology partners and other industry
Partners from small to medium
Enterprises right through to uh you know
hyperscale players like Microsoft but
presumab I mean could this relationship
deep in over time I mean the reason I
ask is because obviously Michael just
done a talk with the London Stock
Exchange group in which they've actually
taken a stake in the LSC could this
relationship with Microsoft deepen in
that way do you think I I think that's
quite a long way ahead from where we are
at the moment what we're what we're
exploring at the moment is uh is
technology and and how we can apply that
uh for our customers problems and I
think you know we will see that grow and
deepen absolutely
um but I wouldn't want to get too far
ahead of ourselves all right Julian it's
been fascinating talking to you today
it's a really interesting deal thanks
for joining us thanks very much
some other business news stories for you
now and shares of super dry have fallen
by as much as 18 this morning after the
fashion retailer and wholesale sellers
said this morning it is considering
raising money from an issue of new
shares Julian Duncan the founder and
chief executive said he would be
prepared to provide material support
during any fundraising as his belief in
the brand was stronger than ever well
the news came as the cheltenham-based
company admitted that retail sales in
February and March had fallen short of
its expectations it said the cost of
living crisis was having a significant
impact on spending and fall well poor
weather had resulted in less demand for
its new spring summer collection the
company now expects to make a loss
during The Current financial year
Dr Martens warned this morning that
prophet's issue will be lower than
expected the boot and Shoemaker whose
shares have lost two-thirds of their
value since they floated on the stock
market in January 2021 blamed higher
costs at its Distribution Center in Los
Angeles it also said its wholesale
revenues during the final three months
of last year had fallen short of
expectations and that expects underlying
earnings to come in at 245 million
pounds that was done from his previous
forecast of between 250 to 260 million
pounds
the online electrical Goods retailer AO
World said this morning that recent
trading had been better than it
previously feared the company said that
since its last update to the market at
the end of February it had continued to
see positive traction it added to the
potential adverse effects and trading
risks continue macroeconomic uncertainty
and tough consumer environment that we
anticipated at the end of February have
not materialized to the extent and
Visage the shares are currently ahead by
some 10 percent
and the recruitment company Hayes said
this morning that it enjoyed record fees
during the first three months of the
year thanks to strong demand for workers
on temporary contracts its biggest
Market amid ongoing labor shortages
around the world fees grew by five
percent on a like-for-like basis during
the quarter but fees for placing
temporary staff and contractors were
ahead by 11 Hayes which specializes in
placing white-collar workers and in the
technology sector highlighted a record
performance in Germany in particular
now there are up to 60 million credit
cards in circulation in the UK with
two-thirds of UK adults having at least
one credit card and one in three of us
having more than one yet there are
suggestions with consumer indebtedness
increasing and Banks and credit card
providers making more than 15 billion
pounds in credit card interest each year
the market is not working as well as it
might for everyone will joining me now
it's Gavin Shuka he's a former labor MP
and he's now chief executive of cardio
which is a credit card management
startup Gavin good to see you this
morning so why do you say the credit
card Market is broken well our research
shows that you've got about 14 million
credit card customers in the UK paying
interest on their balances every month
typically they're spending a thousand
pounds a year just in interest charges
alone that's a huge debt anchor on
household finances and we at Cardio
believe that we could use some of the
regulatory measures such as open banking
to release their data and actually
reduce their costs that's the most
important thing that government can be
doing to help you better explain by
reminding the uninitiated what you mean
by open Banking and this came in in
2018. yeah absolutely actually when I
was a member of parliament this was
coming uh through at that point open
banking is a very simple principle it
says that you as the customer own your
own data and if you want to make that
data available to a third-party provider
such as cardio you can do it with their
permission in other words it allows us
to do clever things with data from
credit card statements and so on that
end up reducing the amount of money that
a customer ends up paying
um it's a regulatory regime that's
pro-market pro-consumer
actually it's a shame that we haven't
made further strides since 2018 on it
yeah so I mean it seems to be working
pretty well in the banking sector you
you say it doesn't with credit cards why
is that yeah so the underlying principle
here is that if the data is made
available to a customer in an electronic
form it should be made available to a
third-party provider now some bits of
the industry are working really well so
like your current accounts we've all
seen the apps where you can put your
accounts together and see what you spent
for example with credit cards actually
enforcement isn't as good and so a lot
of the key data fields that we need to
really save customers money aren't there
because the credit card issuers aren't
compliant with the law and they're not
compliant with the law so this so this
isn't an issue of the regulation not
working they're not adhering to the law
yeah absolutely so the principal under
open banking is very very clear in this
respect but we're using a bit of the
open banking specification that perhaps
other businesses haven't used before
it's not surprising that some of the
data there is patchy but what it needs
is clear political leadership to say
there's a clear principle here in favor
of the consumer let customers have their
data and let us do clever things with it
that save them money I know you've
spoken to the city Minister Andrew
Griffith about this what's the financial
conduct Authority got to say about this
yeah we've engaged with the FCA and
obviously we're in FCA regulated
business in our own right as well they
do take enforcement action where issues
are raised with them but that
enforcement action is confidential it's
one of the reasons why we actually think
there should be a One-Stop shop where
enforcement can be done by a regulator
it's a bit of a patchwork at the moment
but actually with clear political
leadership we could really make open
banking work and save money for
consumers who you uh saying is at fault
here is it the likes of MasterCard and
Visa or is it the issuing Banks
themselves it's the credit card issuers
themselves The High Street Banks and the
other players in the industry that
actually need to go further in terms of
open banking invest in that area and
make that data available is this
conspiracy I think it's a mix of both as
I said before we're doing something
incredibly Innovative at Cardio we're
using open banking in a way that no one
else has used before but that was the
idea of being bringing the regime in in
the first place it's not surprising
we're hitting these kind of issues but
as I say these are the kind of issues
that really impact a consumer we could
say the customer hundreds of pounds each
year just simply through managing their
credit card repayments on their behalf
we can't do that to the extent we want
to today and that's why we're calling
for Action so your app is free to use
how does the business make money yeah
sure so free to use we never charge a
customer money to handle say a single
monthly payment that gets to the right
card right time right amount in terms of
Revenue what we hope to be able to offer
is refinancing for a smaller subset of
users
fundamentally and you'd probably expect
this given my background it's a socially
responsible model what we are trying to
do is actually save customers money
that's the only way in which we can make
money that's actually quite a virtuous
circle for us and that's why and we're
seeing such popularity well it's quite
interesting I mean I see a lot of
business people go into politics I don't
see many politicians going the other way
yeah I've been reflecting on that quite
a lot in recent years as you can imagine
and in terms of running a startup
business one of the things you need is
investment I would say for a lot of VC
firms or investors there's a lack of
pattern recognition why would a
politician make a good chief executive
actually in my experience I think it's
quite a good breeding ground for many of
the skills that you do need
um in terms of managing stakeholders
investors and others having the height
of a rhino yeah yeah a thick skin does
go a long way I understand in business
as well as in politics absolutely and I
mean you left the labor party because of
Jeremy corbyn's leadership what do you
think of uh kirst armor how do you think
he's doing well look there's no doubt at
all that the leg part is in a
fundamentally different place to where
it was in 2019 where I and others uh
shows on a matter of Integrity to leave
the labor party at the same time you
know that work is in my view unfinished
and my good friend Luciana Berger has
chosen to go back to the labor party
I've not made that choice that may be a
reflection of actually me putting all of
my initiative at the moment into
building this great socially responsible
business but I'm enjoying uh engaging as
a voter rather than as a participant for
now all right Gavin good to see you this
morning thanks for joining me
still to come here on inking live we're
gonna have a look at how the markets are
doing this Friday morning the footsie's
in line for its fourth successive Weekly
game join me for more after this short
break
foreign
[Music]
last night's game's on Wall Street were
followed by a positive overnight session
for equities in the Asia Pacific region
all of the main indices in the region
finished higher than Nikka and Tokyo was
the staff of Homer finishing up a one
and a quarter percent nearly it's
finished high and I for six straight
sessions which is the nikkei's best
winning streak since July last year and
that was partly down to fast retailing
which is the owner of Uniqlo it finished
up more than eight percent on strong
quarterly earnings well in Europe right
now all of the main indices are
similarly in positive territory right
now as you can see there a bit by not
very much but they're heading in the
right direction uh talking points this
morning in Continental Europe include
the luxury goods group Hermes the shares
are ahead by one percent in Paris
following a trading update we heard from
lvmh of course on Wednesday night we're
here in London the ftse 100 is also in
positive territory right now currently a
quarter of one percent higher just now
currently on course as I said before the
break for its fourth consecutive Weekly
game the leading Blue Chip Gainer right
now in percentage terms is the warehouse
owner seagro there's been some positive
broker comment lately about around both
the sector and that particular company
while the paper and packaging groups
Murphy Kappa it shares also ahead by
some one and a half percent now roughly
on broker comment outside the ftse 100
quite a lot going on this morning uh the
uh Triple Eight Holdings which is the
owner of William Hill it shares as you
can see on the screen they're currently
aired by some 18 they've got a training
update app today well Deco
Pharmaceuticals the shares there ahead
by nearly 35 and that is following an
after-hours takeover approach last night
from the private Equity Firm eqt that
would value the company used to be in
the ftse at 4.6 billion pounds another
mid cap to mention Is AO world the
shares there currently ahead by 11 on
the trading update it's lifted Asos up
by a third of one percent in sympathy in
boohoo as well I'm not sure why there's
a read across from electrical Goods to
uh fashion retailing online but uh
that's uh that's the way the World Turns
I guess on the foreign exchange markets
well this Euro has hit its highest level
against the US dollar for a year that is
on expectations that the European
Central Bank will carry on raising
interest rates even as the U.S federal
reserve calls a halt to its rate
tightening the Euro ahead by seventh of
one percent right now against the US
dollar Sterling more or less unchanged
against the Greenback but uh yeah the
Euro does have a bit of lead in its
pencil this morning the pound is off by
a fifth of one percent Against The
single currency right now as for the oil
price well that is on course for its
third weekly gain in four about a Brent
crude though more or less unchanged
right now 86 dollars and seven cents a
barrel and another commodity to show you
this morning we don't talk about it all
that often but I thought it was worth
mentioning today the price of gold well
it's continuing to trade close to its
record high which was hit in the summer
of 2020 gold hit 2055 uh uh dollars 30
cents per troy ounce uh yesterday that
was uh taking it up 13 so far on the air
the price right now it's off for 2 000
to 137
5.61 cents an ounce that's off a fifth
of one percent right now but do you want
to be this morning is the lead Equity
Analyst at Hargreaves Lansdowne Sophie
Lund Yates Sophie good to see you this
morning and you're joining us from
Cheltenham which is also very
appropriate because uh we start today
with super dry I mean uh a real humding
a reverse statement this
yes that's a probably a not a good way
to put it but certainly the way I would
phrase it I mean looking at the super
joint shares this morning they're down
about 19 so this just tells you that the
scale of the reaction
um essentially they have said that
trading recent trading hasn't been as
good as expected or indeed needed and
that means that profit expectations have
been downgraded
um really this is just the latest
installment in what has become really a
very much uphill battle for the group
you know they've blamed the cost of
living crisis and there is certainly
merits to this argument you know and you
consider that kind of middle of the
value chain fashion like Superdry
um but those those are the names that
get the most squeezed when times are
tough
um they've done a lot on the cost saving
front credit where it's due that you
know that has been quite Swift
um but cost savings can only take you so
far at some points we are going to need
to see organic demand really picking up
the mantle and yeah really very very
difficult read of a trading statement
this morning from Super dry where do you
think it went wrong for super dry Sophie
was it just that the product became too
ubiquitous or was it the fact that sort
of old geezers like me were wearing it
instead of sort of hip young kids in
their 20s
it's really there are a few bits and
Bobs really that that caused the the
decline of this scale but it really does
come down to the fact that it was a
heavily branded
um product and now obviously in some in
some spheres that can and that can carry
you
um into prosperous times for many many
years but essentially what happened is
is the is the fashion changed
um as you were alluding to there um
fashion is a particularly difficult
Arena
um to do well in when you are very
heavily branded
um and as you say the demographic of who
was wearing super dry did to change
um and it became frankly it became less
cool
um and when you rely on your brand as
much as they do and you know it was very
um very well known for its you know
having its brand kind of emblazoned on
on everything
um and it had that kind of Boom to bust
story unfortunately because of that and
it's not the first name to do so I mean
it certainly won't be the last no you're
absolutely right well on a brighter note
the statement from AO world uh this
morning has gone down quite well
it has indeed I have to say I've been
rooting for AOL that's had a really
really difficult
um time in recent years
um and it said that trading has been
better than expected and has upgraded
profits um it's not the first time it's
done that this year
um which is really no mean fee in the
current environment when you look at the
cost of living crisis things like
electrical Goods white goods are the
kind of thing but it's very difficult to
convince people to buy
um so again very positive but what I
would say before we get too carried away
and as much as progress shouldn't be
knocked you know this is still a company
where ebit margins operating margins are
very much in the low single digits you
know they're expected to be under 2 this
year and so that means there is very
little Breathing Room really
um for things to for things to go wrong
um but yeah current momentum very
positive but I will certainly be keeping
an eye on things because as we know the
macroeconomic landscape at the moment is
incredibly uncertain and that could
change quite quickly absolutely and I
mean one thing feeding into that of
course is the oil device which is
flirting with a two-month high right now
it is indeed so bright crew today
mentioning it just though it's trading
at around 86 dollars a barrel
um today as you say close to two month
highs
um and really this is coming from the
fact that China obviously is an
incredibly important importer has upped
its Imports so that's that's adding
pressure to the demand side at the same
time you've got the supply constraints
con constraints coming from that OPEC
plus cut earlier this month
um and as you rightly point out this has
wide ramifications potentially for
inflation we know that this is the core
metric for that's keeping inflation so
high and also on the consumer Side High
Energy prices feed into higher food
prices as well as other areas of the
economy so you know really consumers
especially and businesses are going to
really want to see that start tempering
so if you before let you go quick word
on Diageo then that's their delisting
from the Irish Stock Market I must admit
I'd forgotten they were even listed
there
yes well this is an interesting one
isn't it because they make they make
Guinness so if the Optics of the
Guinness maker stepping away from
Ireland it's quite easy to
um to look at that as a bigger news than
it than it might be essentially the
reason behind this is the fact that
having multiple listings in multiple
jurisdictions is complex and it's
expensive so operationally diagio is
still very much the the business that we
that we know and we know it's a
well-liked stock in the UK
um but really this does show us that
they're doubling down efforts to focus
on London uh you know they've got about
73 million pound Brewery opening up in
in autumn in Covent Garden things like
that um but essentially what this means
for the business overall
um is is not a lot but certainly a shame
to see the Guinness maker leave Island I
would say yeah it's all very symbolic in
the uh on the day that Joe Biden's there
Sophie got to leave it there good to see
you this morning thank you
thank you
yeah talking to Joe Biden we're keeping
a lot about his Irish relatives I want
to hear more about his ones from West
Sussex but maybe that's a story for
another day still to come here on Ian
King live with a growing number of small
and medium-sized businesses struggling
to survive we'll find out what can be
done to Stave off insolvency don't go
away
[Music]
welcome back well following interest
rate Rises over the last year Rising
costs and the recent removal of
government support with energy bills
life continues to be tough for many
small and medium-sized businesses
company insolvences in February which is
the most recent month for which figures
are available we're up 17 on February
last year and up 33 on February 2020
prior to the pandemic so what can smes
under Financial pressure do to Stave off
the risk of insolvency well joining me
now is Andrew pepper he's a partner and
head of restructuring at the corporate
advisory firm resolve Andrew morning to
you are you getting a lot more inbound
inquiries just now
uh good morning Ian yes we at resolve
are actually got in quite a few but
they're not just about an insolvency
they're all about restructuring they're
all about what can you do as a
management team to solve your problem
today they're not failures but they are
people thinking that there will be
problems in the future
so what are the key things that any SME
that is facing itself in Dire Straits
needs to think about
uh plan act early be flexible if you
think about it when we had covered
people were thinking oh my god I've got
to do something about my structure my
work why allow the economy why allow
covid to change your mind why don't you
just get in front of the problem so
taking action early cash cash is so
important if we can get a cash Runway
which lasts six months how do we extend
it to seven or eight months an extra
month of cash you can do so much in that
time you can help the business so much
so it's All About Management flexibility
what about the approach of the banks
right now how sympathetic are they being
I think in the last couple of recessions
banks were quite notorious for being
quite negative I think they've changed
their game completely if you go to a
bank now you're often getting a very
sympathetic hearing no Bank wants to
cause a problem it's not good for their
PR they don't make the money they used
to do out of it and therefore the
mindset has completely changed I think
you go to most banks now and my
experience at resolve our experience of
resolve is that Banks want to help you
can't push them to a stupid decision but
if you put a fair plan forward on the
whole you get a fair response and that's
a very very different matter than
perhaps in the 80s and the 90s where
some of the banks had a better
reputation so the key thing then is for
a small business owner not to stick
their head in the sand but to be
proactive go and talk to their their
lending bank and try and thrash out a
deal I think in the mid-market
um people are very much believing their
business is their business if you look
at a PLC it's the shareholders business
they're a professional management when
you're talking about a business that's
10 20 30 million turn over it feels like
it's my own business and therefore
having that belief in yourself having
the belief that the management will turn
around the business is actually a huge
positive in today's economy so therefore
people just getting out in front of the
problem is so critical at this moment
and we at resolve are seeing that all
the time it's amazing how many positive
constructive conversations we have with
management teams who come into the
meeting fearful but end up being oh my
gosh it's brilliant I can actually do
this I didn't feel liberated sometimes
those the word recession sounds
traumatic but it's actually a catalyst
to change it gets people thinking about
what is the art of the possible
is going into Administration always the
answer because that obviously is a way
of continuing to trade while keeping
your your creditors at arm's length
um sometimes Administration is the only
way but there are so many more tools
available to people like us at resolve
um you can have a CVA you can have a
debt a deal you can do an informal
Arrangement your creditors just because
you're having cash problems or business
problems doesn't mean it's the end there
are so many more things you can do as a
management team however waiting until
you can't pay your bill waiting until
the day before payroll is due does not
give you any chance or very limited
chance of resolving that if you think
there's a problem in the next month try
and work out what can I do today so
therefore tomorrow I can do things
waiting around and just hoping isn't
going to work
now liquidations where a company is
completely wound up are also on the rise
and apparently that's because we're
getting a lot more winding up petitions
from hm revenue and Customs why are they
taking a harder line do you think
I'm not sure I think in in one sense
during covid they were very relaxed so
you had very a large number of uh
companies being able to not pay their
pay not pay their HMR hmrc debt and I
think there must have been a reaction
within hmrc to say this can no longer
continue so I think there's a basically
a hard thing of attitudes however
um if you put forward a reasonable
opportunity to hmrc to get its money
back if it's owed half a million pounds
putting the cup into liquidation it gets
zero if you can come up with a deal that
allows hmrc to get back some of his
money on the whole hmrc will work with
you to deliver that but again it has to
be sensible timely it has to be
practical You Can't Hide you've got to
go and talk to these guys they on the
whole will look after you but they will
not look after you if you're silly and
effectively do not give them an honest
and straightforward plan
all right Andrew good leave it there
appreciate the wise words this morning
thank you thank you very much cheers
now millions of bathroom products are
thrown away annually much of its
single-use plastic addressing that issue
was the motivation for the entrepreneurs
behind the natural deodorant brand wild
which sells reusable deodorant
applicators made from aluminum and
bamboo pulp deodorant refills I spoke to
the co-founder Charlie Bose lion and
began by asking him how the covert
pandemic affected his business
so it was it was a bit of a strange time
as you you might imagine we
operationally had a lot of difficulties
because as a small business we were we
were bottom of the pile and
manufacturers dropped us first before
anyone else
um so we struggled to find ingredients
and we had to ask around a lot of
different people
um whether you know for example I think
my co-founder asked the founder of uh
Lush if they had any spare baking soda
and they kindly responded saying they
did so it was Scrappy but on the on the
flip side
um sales were extremely good because
everyone was sat at home uh they were on
their social medias so ads became a lot
cheaper and I think you know in in some
ways from a kind of marketing
perspective it was quite a advantageous
time to normal why was baking soda such
a critical ingredient for you
so baking soda is um the ingredient
within our natural deodorant that
essentially kills the bacteria that
makes you smell so
um you know in the typical
antiperspirant you have elemental salts
which which block your pores and and
stop you sweating and therefore smelling
but baking soda doesn't block your pores
but it does attack the different
bacterias that
um end up creating odor and sets is
pretty important for a DHR absolutely I
mean one interesting thing is that which
I hadn't realized is that there are
different sorts of sweats that are
different sorts of deodorants have to
tackle yeah exactly so I think
um everybody's body is different and and
everyone has different kind of pH uh in
their sweat and as a result different
deodorants work differently some people
might get a rash from a uh
antiperspirant for example and that's
because they're reacting to it from
their body's pH so
um no one's quite the same but I think
uh the idea of using natural ingredients
is that they're you know generally
ingredients people have heard of
um most of our ingredients are
moisturizing are good for your skin
things that you could probably eat if
you wanted to
um not that we advise it but
um so you know going to be much better
for you and much safer and less likely
to irritate your skin and how did you
hit on the idea of having a refillable
reusable deodorant was a sort of Eureka
moment as it were well my partner um
Fred and I sat down and we want we knew
we wanted to do something in
sustainability and we we looked around
the household and there were kind of
companies that were doing pretty well in
the kitchen whether it was laundry or
dishwasher tablets
um and elsewhere you know most people
have recycling bins in their highs that
differentiate from their normal bins but
in the bathroom there wasn't really
anything uh to do that and most people
have you know several bathroom products
with it's shampoo shower gel toothpaste
to that deodorants they all go in their
bathroom Ben and then typically just go
in their General waist so very little of
this was getting recycled and we felt
like we could take you know products um
to launch with natural deodorant that
typically hasn't worked that well
historically in the UK make a really
great one that
um we could guarantee work for people
and then on top of that provide
completely sustainable packaging where
there'd be no waste and
um ultimately start to reduce
um you know the plastic waste in the
bathroom and and that's something we
hate to do not just across the agent but
the kind of all bathroom products that's
done going on now you've raised seven
and a half million pounds to date from
investors will you at some point have to
go through another fundraising to get
where you want to be uh possibly it's
something we're discussing at the moment
I think our our core
um aim at the moment is to be a
profitable business which we've been for
the last four or five months and
that's very important to us so things
like cash flow at top of the agenda but
I think
um it's it's a different climate now
with
um VCS not so readily piling money into
companies that are unprofitable and and
for us we really want to have our
destiny in our own hands and if that
means you know maybe we do one more
fundraise uh to get there then then
that's fine but ultimately we know that
we need to be on a path that's
um you know not only sustainable as a
business but sustainable in terms of
cash flow and profit as well it must be
quite lonely at times though because
you're up against some really really big
powerful multinationals the likes of
Unilever and Nivea and so forth I mean
you've got to have a lot of guts to take
those sort of guys on
I think
um
we see ourselves in a different space in
so far as as a startup we are able to
innovate really quickly so for example
if we realize you know something in the
packaging isn't working tomorrow we can
get onto our manufacturers create the
Tooling in a couple of months time have
a different product for someone like
Unilever you know they have to do things
in five-year terms they have to make
decisions now for probably the next 10
years and we're just able to move much
faster and and that will kind of always
be ahead of the game and what we've seen
in the last couple of years is
um people or other companies have
started to create similar products to us
um I think even even the big companies
are starting to bring in similar
mechanisms into their own products but
it's far slower and as long as we can
stay entrepreneurial and
um you know ahead of the game I think
we'll always have a first mover
advantage
[Music]
time for a look at this morning's
business Pages now the financial times
leads both its print and digital
editions with the aftermath of ey's
decision not to go ahead with a plan to
split its audit and Consulting
businesses the Ft says Partners have
been warned to prepare for a fresh
cost-cutting plan and a stream of Staff
departures us a result the Ft also
reports on its front page that the cost
of buying insurance against the U.S
government default has shot to its
highest level in more than a decade in
an early sign of Market concerns about
the political onpass in Washington over
the debt ceiling the times leaves its
business pages with last night's
takeover bids for dekra pharmaceuticals
and the payment processing group network
International both from private Equity
groups papers says a wave of bids for
London listed companies from overseas
buyers have been expected after the
pound weakened last year against the US
dollar the times also reports that the
former I.T chief of TSB who presided
over the system's meltdown that crippled
the lender five years ago has been fined
nearly 82 000 pounds by the bank of
England meanwhile the Delhi Telegraph
leads its business pages with news at
less than half of the 150 million pounds
allocated for household grants to
install heat pumps was used in the
scheme's first year the telegraph also
reports that home landlords fear they
face fees of up to one thousand pounds a
year under the housing secretary Michael
gove's cracked down on bike to let
properties for joining me as ever on a
Friday morning is the financial markets
commentator and evening standard
columnist Neil Collins Neil good to see
you this morning you've written on the
IMF and some very sagacious words I
think you've come up with too you're
quite cynical about the IMF it's fair to
say well I'm quite cynical about all
these is it's essentially state-funded
or officially funded economic
forecasters I think a lot of the
things that they used to do and be
useful for are now done just as well and
much quicker by the private sector in
terms of the likes of capital economics
and the economics Departments of the big
Banks and financial institutions who can
not only do the same number crunching
but they can do it much quicker so uh
what they say is much more current the
problem with the IMF particularly is
that it's it has this sort of process
through which its uh suggestions
findings forecasts have got to go and by
the time it comes through the sausage
machine it's certainly weak sold and
possibly even months old and as we can
see economics changes quite quickly
I think the other thing I would say is
that it is always going to be a hugely
inexact science and the great thing
about science generally is if you
produce the same conditions you should
get the same result but of course that's
never going to be true in economics
because even if you did get the same
conditions people would react in a
different way so even the the history is
of only uh limited value if you're
trying to forecast the future which is
basically what economics has got to be
about otherwise it's just a sort of um
bit of academic Factor fact chewing
because we want to know what's going to
happen next of course and it's almost
impossible to say so I just wonder
whether these big institutions have um
outlived their usefulness in this regard
I do think
what do you think the IMF has such a
terrible track record of forecasting
what's going on here in the UK in
particular
I don't think they really understand how
the UK economy works and I think that a
lot of us would share that puzzlement
because it's uh often it looks as though
it shouldn't work at all but it does
um and I think it's much more resilient
than a lot of these outside forecasters
think we are quite flexible uh the
private sector sector particularly is
pretty flexible we have a very strong
base of uh of smaller companies and
indeed they're very small companies like
the one that you've just been uh talking
about
um innovating and uh quietly prospering
uh were the the large ones which we
obviously look at all the time are
international and may not have a great
deal of impact on the UK economy so I
suspect that the the iron have
underestimates this uh this factor and
this thing which does help us which is
why things seldom turn out to be as bad
as they think it's going to be
a good point now what do you make of all
these takeover bids in the mid cap
sector just now obviously the times has
led with this today I mean it is very
clear the UK stock market is on a fairly
cheap rating compared with some of its
Global peers
well you've answered your own question
really
um the UK sock Market as uh any follower
would know has been a very poor
performer uh over the in recent years
and the the obverse of that is that the
highly rated stocks in in the US
particularly look across the Atlantic
and see Bargains and I think this is
going to continue because in my view
um a lot of these companies are
undervalued it's partly a uh a lack of
investment by the big domestic investors
the Pension funds and life insurance
companies has taken their money overseas
um and it's partly because uh the
currency has been weak and that has a
sort of psychological effect on uh the
Predators who are who are looking here
but really if you you look at the
ratings of some very good businesses
probably outside the ftse hundred
there are some really quite low ratings
for pretty decent businesses so I think
we're going to see quite a lot more of
that
yeah very interesting to watch Neil good
to see you as ever thanks for joining me
today
pleasure
still to come here on air King life the
government's push for homes to go solar
but how many people are actually making
the switch don't go away
[Music]
to the latest news and insight
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
welcome back one little noted measure in
the government's energy security Day
package unveiled two weeks ago was a
pledge to establish a Joint Task Force
and roadmap to drive the further growth
of solar energy ministers are seeking a
five-fold increase in solar power
generation by 2035 up to 70 gigawatts
which would be enough to power around 20
million homes what a tovo is a Norwegian
company that runs an online Marketplace
which connects homeowners with local
vetted and approved installers of solar
panels well joining me now is a tovo's
UK general manager Gina Quan Gina
welcome to you at the current rate of
progress we're not going to hit that
Target are we
actually we think that we definitely
could meet that rate of progress looking
at the current rates of installation in
the UK we've seen tremendous increase uh
and catching up to Europe on rates of
residential solar installation so
looking at last year's installation
rates we're looking at a three-fold
increase over the two years prior wow so
what's going to be Central to hitting
that Target so we think there are a
couple things that atova that can really
help Drive the adoption of solar so
first of all just naturally looking at
increasing the rate of solar in the UK
currently it's about seven percent uh in
other European countries you've got in
the Netherlands over 20 percent once you
start to see your neighbors your friends
your colleagues starting to adopt solar
it becomes less of a foreign thing more
is something that's obvious in adoption
most solar panels are used around the
world are manufactured in China would it
help at all if we had a domestic
manufacturing capability definitely so
if we take a look at the major panel
manufacturers they do come from China
they're the ones who have the the
highest output so far we're a European
company uh for the British company we're
based in the UK and it's something that
we're really committed to is is really
rolling out more uh domestic and
European kind of manufacturing of solar
and supporting the industry so tell me
about your business I mean you listed on
the Norwegian stock market you're in 13
European countries already including
Germany France Spain Italy what's taking
you so long to come to the UK
so we thought that last year was a
perfect opportunity to enter the the
British Market uh at a Tova we've been
around for several years we're in 13
different markets uh really what we
wanted to do was was time the entry at
the right Point uh there were you know
the first wave of solar happened in the
UK about 10 15 years ago uh successful
but we wouldn't say the most efficient
roll out in the way that the government
used subsidies and incentives to drive
that adoption now we think that with the
removal actually of those subsidies and
incentives and really in the last three
years looking at things like the
pandemic looking at the war in Ukraine
uh inflation rates and how that's really
affected consumers and how they've
really been affected by the
vulnerability of living on an island
nation and Rising electricity prices
that solar really makes a lot of sense
at this point it is still a big upfront
cost so for most homeowners absolutely
so we recognize that it's a long-term
investment uh solar at atovo and what
we're really working to do in the UK is
what we have adopted in our other
European markets was a leasing product
so really we're committed to making
solar accessible to most households do
we have the sort of skills base to to
install all these panels absolutely so
in the UK we've got over 2 000 certified
installers that are registered with MCS
which is the qualification board for
solar installation and we only work with
the best uh installers at atova from
from that list there's definitely
increasing demand from consumers to get
more solar onto roof so uh really
looking to kind of roll out and help
more installers kind of get on board as
well are there a few Cowboys out there
then absolutely so this is something
that we've seen in the UK quite a lot uh
especially seeing the the first rate of
adoption of solar uh 10 15 years ago
it's something that otoba really helps
to uh
bring down all right Gina got to leave
that I'm afraid good to see you this
morning thank you thank you very much
from me I'm back on Monday at 10 o'clock
hope very much to see you then in the
meantime do stay tuned after this short
break it's Nick Qureshi cheerio
[Music]